الاخير فقط الوضع القانوني الالي اشرف
حكيمي هل هو مخول بمغادره الاراضي
الفرنسيه هو تحت الرقابه القضائيه ماذا
بعد ذلك
انا
السيد حكيمي وضع تحت مراقبه قضائيه
وبالتالي ان العداله او القضاء تطلب من
السيد حكيمي بان يعلن عن مكان تواجده
ولكنها حر تماما بالتحرك وبالذهاب الى حيث
يشاء ان القضاء يراقب هناك عدد من
المواضيع او الاجراءات المفروضه على السيد
حكيمي ولكن الاهم هو الا يكون هناك علاقه
او تواجد لحكيمي مع هذه السيده ولكن ليس
هناك قرار من القانون او من من القاضي
التحقيق بان يغادر او ان يبقى في فرنسا هو
حر بالتحرك بما لا يؤثر على
حياته المهنيه يستطيع السيد حكيمي ان
يتابع حياته المهنيه بشكل كامل عمله
الرياضي وان يغادر او يعود او يعمل ما
يريد
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المداخله من باريس
المحاميه ماريون ميناج